well listen I'll I'll go second best
because I know I'll come out on top when
I'm finished I feel like you're tricking
me
right so welcome to the next level
kitchen where we're taking your kitchen
skills to the next level by teaching you
the basic tips Great Tricks and more
importantly helping you elevate your
cooking throughout that's right Gordon
and what better way to kick off this
series than by getting deep into one of
America's favorite proteins chicken the
chicken it has to be one of the most
popular proteins anywhere on the planet
right the most delicious let's head to
the first level and walk through some
key things you may not have known about
the humble chicken what's your favorite
piece so for me honestly I'm gonna be a
thigh person a thigh and the Wings come
you know I'm a great yeah there's a lot
of flavor it's on the bone that's where
the flavor is a lot of times so the
cheap cuts are the drums and the thighs
and the wings the expensive cuts are the
breasts the breasts are very unforgiving
so nine times out of ten skin side down
poached or even lightly floured so they
get a touch of color but they need
looking after them because they dry out
quickly this is true that's true breasts
really really tough to cook because
they're super lean but they're also
really healthy for you they are very
healthy good point um I'm gonna cook a
dish you're gonna cook a dish I know
you're gonna go straight for those eyes
I feel like you're tricking me I'm
taking the breasts I'm gonna take the
breasts I'm taking the breast
right I'm gonna do thighs this is a dish
that I cook for the kids all the time
especially at weekends it's a sticky
lemon sort of saute chicken with crushed
potatoes so super simple and this is a
real go-to staple at the weekend
especially with a full household yeah I
love it I love it because it's really
forgiving right
it's juicy it's tender and nine times
out of ten when you're cooking chicken
on the boat everyone panics about the
bone and it not been cooked props you
take your knife get the tip and just go
through and just gently go through and
what happens now when we start to sear
those thighs all that heat goes through
to the Bone and there's no pink
especially for the kids right yeah I
love that and I actually don't do this
sort of paringite bit right there so
that's something you're teaching me I
appreciate that touch of oil okay I'm
gonna get the sticky bit in a minute
first of all get that oil up okay skin
side down why it's because that's where
all the flavor is so we go in whack up
the gas start off rendering that fat
down
and then from there literally
keep them skin side down I don't like
throwing away all that seasoning I'm a
big sticker once you've seasoned your
chicken get All That season into the pan
now they wash the hands
so once you've got that nice little
Sizzle and that's it on there keep the
heat in the pan now we're going to start
with the sticky caramelized lemon get
your lemon
and literally just nice long wedges
we're not taking the Pips out we're not
gonna
zest it I want the lemon literally just
in
getting nice and fragrant I love that
yeah that is a nice tip right there and
I love that I love the fruit like sticky
lemon yeah it just sounds appetizing to
me yeah when my kids were growing up
they call this the Posh chicken they
know it's the cheapest cup they thought
because of the stickiness and how
anxious and delicious they were it was
past chicken that that is truly Next
Level if you got your kids eating
chicken thighs bone in chicken thighs as
well absolutely now the breasts yeah so
let's listen my kids maybe not as Posh
but like you know living in California
super into fitness they want the chicken
breast even though it kills me Gordon as
a chef sometimes to cook a boneless
skinless chicken breast but that's what
I have right here now what do I love
about chicken breasts is that it is lean
you have to be really careful about it
and you want to make sure that you don't
overcook it so to not overcook it what
I'm going to do is a technique called
butterflying the breast and what I'm
just going to take is my paring knife
and then just make a little bit of an
insert into the actual breast fillet
right here to sort of open it up sort of
make it into this heart shape nice and
what that's going to do is it thins out
the chicken you can see how thin it is
right now and it's going to cook a lot
quicker uh and this is perfect if you
only have 10 minutes left you're on some
you're on the bottom level you got 10
minutes left you have to cook something
quick butterfly the chicken so of course
what I'm going to do now is I have a pan
heating up and I want to season my
chicken I'm also serving mine Gordon
with potatoes so we have some
similarities going on here I'm going to
toss my potatoes in like a salsa verde
uh and then I'm gonna make a quick sauce
for that a little bit of salad but first
thing I'm going to do of course get my
pan hot it's so important to get a pan
hot and then I'm going to season my
chicken breast you gotta season from way
up top why do you season from up high it
gets the salt and the pepper all over
the chicken it disperses the seasoning
and that's going to give us some tasty
delicious food so I got hot cast iron
pan and this is another tip that I love
I'm going to use clarified butter or
ghee it's butter that have the milk
solids removed so that the butter is not
going to Brown but it's giving gonna
give me that golden brown sort of crust
and that buttery flavor that I want how
do you know when to cook you saw
Gordon's pan he had to get it hot same
thing here even maybe more important for
the chicken breast because it's so thin
and I don't want to overcook it you can
see and I'm looking at the pan I can see
the smoke when it just starts to smoke
that's perfect I'm going to start
cooking my chicken and Gordon I'm going
to send it back over to you here right
now that chicken's got really nice and
colored okay I've turned it over so you
can see that skin caramelizing and now
you can start to see that lemon
literally getting very sticky take your
knife again and just pierce the top of
that skin closer to the Bone and this is
going to ramp up and speed up that
process now I've got garlic shallots a
little bit of thyme in there and now my
lemons start to caramelize okay
but I've got these potatoes they're
leftover ball potatoes from last night's
dinner and all I'm doing is getting them
on a flat surface and pressing them down
because once I've seared that chicken
okay I'm gonna use the chicken flavor
from that fat to cook these potatoes in
so
shallots caramelizing nice and sweet
lemon doing this job
take the chicken out okay and with the
same fat now stick my potatoes in okay
and what happens here is these potatoes
get really nice and crispy all that
lovely flavor the time the garlic the
slots lemon and potatoes trust me really
really really good I love that and a key
lesson there right is all of the flavor
from the chicken like you just said are
now getting soaked up into those
potatoes it's a one part meal pretty
unbelievable and fantastic let's grab a
spatula over here see how we're doing on
our our chicken getting nice and golden
brown now again with the chicken breasts
what I don't want is it to be super
super dark I want it to be just nice and
golden brown so I'll flip the chicken
and then I'm going to start basting this
right I don't care if it's the humble
chicken breast and it doesn't cost a lot
of money I want to treat it like it's on
the third level even if it's a bottom
level dish I'm gonna take my garlic
clove and then just smash the garlic I'm
gonna toss some garlic in the pan I'm
gonna toss a cup sprigs of thyme in the
pan and then I'm going to throw some
whole butter in there why do I add whole
butter after the clarified butter
because now I want that whole butter
flavor that nuttiness of the butter and
now this is where you have maybe a you
know a six dollar chicken breast you're
going to treat it like a sixty dollar
steak in a restaurant and I'm just gonna
baste this I'm just gonna baste this
chicken and get all that butter flavor
in there it's in a sort of butter garlic
jacuzzi okay I'm cooking this breast
it's almost done Gordon what do you got
going on over there I've just called the
chicken thighs into the oven for the
moment I'm turning these potatoes over
and getting really nice and sort of
crispy now here's where the magic and
the sticky part starts going to
overdrive we call it a smashed potato so
the squash so they get them really nice
and crispy the starch is still in there
taking this dish to the next level I'm
frying my potatoes in all that delicious
chicken flavor
and here's how the chicken becomes a
sticky lemon chicken take a touch of soy
sauce
that helps to make it really nice and
season give that nice dark richness as
well
a little touch of Sherry vinegar you
could use white wine vinegar Cherry with
a chicken delicious just a touch from
there a little bit of honey
and literally
a tablespoon of honey
beautiful
and now you can see how this thing's
coming together almost like a little
glaze a sticky soy glaze a couple of
tablespoons
of stock
and then we get our chicken out the oven
keeping the momentum and now that's
going to go back in
it looks amazing over here I got the
boneless skinless chicken breast it's
just about done I'm waiting for that to
finish the brown butter is in the pan
now I have to make my sauce because your
sauce is next level already and this is
going to be a super humble sauce it's
just a salsa verde or a chimichurri it's
parsley and it's tarragon that's what I
have on the board right here with a
little bit of garlic and then I'm gonna
get in here you can pop it in the
blender if you want but maybe you're in
the the basement level kitchen and you
don't have blenders and you're just
going to use your hands you're just
going to take your knife and you're just
gonna mince it up just like this
so rich is doing a really nice sauce I'm
gonna keep this light think about the
sticky lemon chicken in there so I got a
bit of arugula okay lemon zest every
time we got all these beautiful lemons
and oranges at home we're always zesting
take
the juice fresh lemon juice and just a
sprinkling okay of extra virgin olive
oil give that a really nice light toss
and then just mix that up
Ruger is very peppery so it doesn't need
pepper a touch of salt lemon juice lemon
zest and a nice light
coating of juice now just get some
really nice shavings of Parmesan
and I quite like the sort of nice long
curls rather than just grated it's a lot
easier to eat and also it doesn't go
soggy how's that uh beautiful breast of
yours yeah the breast is coming out so I
love this even though you know we're not
gonna eat all this butter I'm gonna let
the breast rest while I finish the sauce
and then I'm just gonna pour over that
brown garlic butter and sort of let that
chicken breast sit in some of that fat
and that butter because the breast
itself is so lean and then back over
here I'm just going to finish up this
salsa verde or this pesto this
chimichurri whatever you want to call it
I'm going to call it delicious we have
parsley we have tarragon but if you like
mint and cilantro and basil put in this
whatever you'd like I'm going to add a
little bit of oil there's some vinegar
in there uh Gordon I don't know how you
feel about Capers but one of my favorite
ingredients of all time Capers bring
that nice salinity the brininess to it
and then uh listen I live in California
I love jalapenos so we're going to make
this a little spicy we're gonna add some
diced jalapeno and because parsley and
olive oil sometimes can be a little
bitter I'm just going to put a squeeze
of honey in there just to offset some of
that bitterness and now I have my
dressing what am I going to do with it
I'm going to toss my potatoes in it now
you made those amazing smashed potatoes
you got all that texture yes I'm gonna
do what I tell my chefs on Next Level
Chef to do sometimes let a potato just
be a potato just the small little
potatoes have been steamed another key
ingredient that I'm going to toss into
this sauce anchovy paste love that it's
got a little bit of umami Umami is a
Savory flavor it's going to wake this
dish up not make it fishy my sauce is
almost done Gordon how are you doing
next little placing you know that you're
gonna go down that little bit of
sophistication and that fine dining room
I want to keep this very simple so
family style start off with a starch and
just build out those beautiful crisp and
potatoes okay so they've been fried in
that chicken fat so the flavor is
delicious a little bit of thyme on there
it's got a little bit of garlic on there
it's a great way of using leftover new
potatoes now give them some like I said
and grab them properly and then look at
this
the chicken let that reduce down into a
beautiful glaze
and then literally lift that over
place now you can see
just how sticky that is
and the sauce is just almost like a sort
of cross between a Light Citrus teriyaki
to the most amazing
beautiful almost like a little fresh
hoisin sauce
I'm gonna keep the garlic in there the
lemon in there because all you do is
squeeze that lemon
over
and then I'm going to drizzle some sauce
I'm gonna use everything in my pan this
whole one pan Wonder
it's got that beautiful charm
and then finally
a nice handful of salad over those
potatoes that gives it the color the
freshness and there we have the
beautiful sticky lemon chicken thighs
Richard oh my gosh Gordon I have to be
honest that is looking like it's ready
for the top level over there sticky
lemon chicken I don't know if I can
compete with you Gordon but I'm gonna
try over here we have these potatoes
that were steamed uh in their jackets
here whole little baby potatoes with
this salsa verde and I'm just gonna
plate these right on top of our boneless
skinless chicken breast I put a little
bit of the pan juices from the potato
into the chicken as well my favorite
little bits here some of the Capers and
some of the herbs I'm going to put on
and then just like you did I have over
here some of these awesome little pea
shoots that I'm just going to clip out
of the window box out of their container
over here I love tissues for their
texture we have a little bit of
watercress salad and I'm not even going
to dress it I'm just gonna barely toss
it in the vinaigrette that was in the
bowl with the potatoes
and then just I always like to do this I
like to tell my chefs let it fall like
it sort of fell maybe from the platform
from level three uh down to the basement
or more importantly maybe like it just
parachuted from the sky a little touch
of zest just to give it that little
touch of vibrancy that looks amazing oh
my God I want to eat yours right now
honestly likewise great job bud well
done
[Music]
you go that's how to take your chicken
dish to the next level now to get the
ingredients and more details than the
recipes from today please check the
description below and be sure to
subscribe for more amazing recipes and
episodes from Rich to myself from The
Next Level kitchen